عبد العزيز درجه على لقائه الملك عبد
العزيز كان يحضر الى مكه قبل الحج بفتره
طويله للاطمئنان على الاجراءات التي ستتم
تقوم بها الجهات الحكوميه
لحج هذه السنه والملكه عبد العزيز كان
يقيم استقبال قبل العيد للبيتات الرسميه
يستقبلهم
ويحضرون معه غسيل الكعبه
وبعدها في لقاء اخر يكون بعد
يوم العيد يوم العيد يوم العيد او يوم 11
وكان هناك لقاء على حسب فاللقاءات هذه
كانت لقاءات مع كبار الحجاج سواء البعثات
الرسميه
وكبار الادباء والمثقفين
والمشاهير من العالم الاسلامي الذين
يحضرون لهذا اللقاء
[موسيقى]
اول شيء يستمع منهم الملك عبد العزيز
اللي اجراءات الحج في هذه السنه يستمع
ايضا كان يلتقي بالبعض لقاء خاص فمثلا
محمد حسين هيكل في الوحي
في منزل الوحي في كتابه ذكر ان الملك عبد
العزيز طلب انه يجلس معه لوحده وجلس معه
وساله يعني عده اسئله فكانت الملك عبد
العزيز يحرص على لقاء الشخصيات
والاستماع اليهم ومعرفه
هل الحج والاجراءات سليمه هل هناك ملاحظات
انه في النهايه الجهات الحكوميه قد لا ترى
كل شيء الافراد قد يرون اشياء لا تراها
الجهات الحكوميه لذلك هو كان حريص على انه
يستمع للاخرين من غير المسؤولين ليتعرف
على
السلبيات بالدرجه الاولى حتى يتم تلا فيها